[Musique]
ah c'est anne hidalgo hidalgo qui s'est
totalement démago ça lui a permis
d'exister quelques semaines parce que
jusqu'à présent la campagne d'algos elle
n'existe pas je pense qu'elle s'aperçoit
que france c'est qu'ils allaient en plus
des parisiens et là aucune chance
ces émaux sur le droit du sol se fait
beaucoup de monde marine le pen eric
zemmour les deux ensemble alors il va
falloir changer la constitution va
falloir en faire des débats et peut-être
un référendum alors ça irait peut-être
dans un package plus large je pense que
c'est une proposition intéressante on
aurait dû faire depuis longtemps
xavier bertrand xavier bertrand oui le
pouvoir d'achat ça va être un sujet
important de la campagne d'aller vers
temps à raison de s'y attaquer dès
maintenant j'ai une prime d'activité
améliorées assez démagogique à mon avis
même si le smic est évidemment trop bas
dans ce moule
totalement illusoire sans doute sandrine
rousseau j'étais jeune yannick jadot
2030 c'est demain sortir du nucléaire ça
prendra des décennies et puis sortir du
nucléaire pourquoi faire tant qu'on n'a
pas les moyens de remplacer l'énergie
nucléaire avec une énergie renouvelable
suffisante ça me paraît extrêmement
compliqué et dangereux alors presque le
nucléaire pose la question bien sûr de
l'approvisionnement en uranium c'est une
autre question mais ça reste pour moi
2030 trop tôt une fort mauvaise idée
puisque on n'a pas de production
d'énergie remplacement et qui d'ailleurs
respectable climat
c'est zemmour si marine le pen et eric
zemmour je crois encore une fois sa
peine je sais plus quel d2 non je pense
qu'il faudrait rendre indépendant le
service public des décisions politiques
on va dire faire qu'on arrête avec le
rtf mais un service public de
l'information peut exister doit exister
mais de manière beaucoup plus
indépendante qu'aujourd'hui c'est une
bonne idée à moins que d'essayer de
rétablir un petit peu de neutralité dans
le service public et de mettre autant de
gauche que de droite parmi ses salariés
et ses journalistes
mélenchon fait pas philippe poutou
peut-être tout à philippe poutou bah oui
pourquoi pas 2000 en même temps un
salaire à vie ça veut dire que c'est des
aides sociales à vie tant que l'argent
est celui magique de la bce pourquoi pas
est une idée qui peut être séduisante
qui malheureusement produira plus
d'effets nocifs que de bons effets
michel barnier s'est pas je alors c'est
toujours ces questions
constitutionnelles je ne pense pas que
ça passionne les français mais c'est
vrai que cinq ans apparaît course étant
fois de sa part l oms étant une fois à
quoi ça sert on passait ses histoires de
non renouvelable pour moi un chef d'état
est meilleur mieux vaut le renouveler
gardez peut-être à vis mon côté
royalistes
c'est valérie pécresse foule y en a
beaucoup michel barnier et xavier
bertrand valérie pécresse eric zemmour
marine le pen nicolas dupont aignan je
pense que ça fait une grosse partie de
la droite et ce en à peu près tous
d'accord là-dessus avec derrière la
promesse d'un référendum sur
l'immigration pourquoi pas mais si des
quotas existent pourquoi de quel pays ça
me paraît être un enfer technocratique
qui s'ouvre sauf que personne ne sait
exactement comment on est trop ça en
oeuvre
[Musique]
je